lead singer of the Happy Mondays and
self-proclaimed melon twister Sean Ryder
and the Fox News contributor across the
pond Tommy layron so let me start with
Sean uh eight great decision
I apprecially good to see you now this
is a raging debate and I spent a lot of
time in America where in 19 States now
marijuana is legal for American citizens
it all to be said not for not for uh
non-american citizens and you know I
will come to Tommy in a moment for her
very on how that's all been going but
certainly massively more open about
legalizing this drug in America than we
are here which seems a little perverse
do you think that we should be catching
up with the Americans and moving to
Legalize It
well I'm going to be quite
controversially at piercing Carl Leon's
secretary a knob
because Draconian rules that you know
I mean what's that going to achieve
that's just ridiculous it's Draconian
and yeah you know I really thought
whatever happens in America whether it's
10 years 20 years it happens here and we
should be taxing it and we should be
making money off it really you know we
need to go forward you know
going backwards you know we need to try
something that hasn't been tried before
in terms of cannabis itself
well sure famously cannabis no one's
ever OD'd on cannabis right it's it's
impossible pretty much they're not it's
no recorded case of somebody having a
lethal overdose academies however I you
know I was yeah I've been lazy well I
was discussing it though before we came
on over some of my own team and they
they have family members some of them
who've had extremely bad experiences
um by taking too much marijuana and you
do read a lot of grim stories about
people who get addicted to it it ruins
their lives it's a gateway drug to more
serious drugs what do you say to that
argument
well cannabis has got a built-in
antidote right and the basic thing about
it is you like to open smoke it and if
you get paranoid you know you stop
smoking it you know once you you know I
mean I smoke for 15 17 years ago one
morning lit up a giant usual thing wake
up skin up and I got powder and I had
another goal and I got powder and I
didn't smoke it again and that's the
same with all my mates you know and
everybody I know so once you start
getting para you stop smoking it
there really isn't any long-term you
know I I'm not having it you know about
there's no withdrawal symptoms they're
not physical withdrawal symptoms they're
more mental you know I want it that
lasts for about a week so
um you know these
it's just ridiculous it really is
Draconian okay let's come to Tommy uh
it's ridiculous and Draconian that the
new British Home Secretary is
considering making this a Class A drug
and incarcerating people for at the
exact moment President Biden is doing of
course the opposite with Americans in
relation to marijuana how do you think
this conversion of many American states
to places where Americans can legally
take this drug how is that gone Tommy
well I'll tell you this I don't usually
believe in Freedom infringement of
really any kind but I'll tell you the
states that have legalized in the United
States if you look at them and you look
at their homeless population their
degenerate population it has expanded
wildly I mean just look at Denver
Colorado it used to be a city that was
very vibrant very hard working and then
they legalized pot and now they have
potheads laying on the side of the
street they have people that travel
there because pot was legalized so I
don't think it attracts the best of the
best you know here in the United States
we allow the states to decide and I'm on
honestly an advocate for states rights I
think if you want to have a class of
people that are potheads that smoke weed
that maybe don't contribute a whole lot
to society your voters need to decide
that but I would tell you tread lightly
on this whole legalize everything
because we've also got States here in
the United States that have said Hey
listen heroin all those other illicit
drugs they're not so bad either we have
shoot up galleries where you can safely
inject I mean we talk about a Snowball
Effect that's what you're seeing in the
United States so be careful what what
you wish for it might seem like it's
just all in good fun just a little weed
until you've got pothead littering your
streets and then you might think a
little bit Tommy do you think it's worse
than alcohol for example
well Hey listen I'm not here to say if
it's worse or better than alcohol I do
know that there are more studies that
are surfacing saying that the long-term
effects of cannabis might be a little
different than some people think but
when we talk about alcohol people
usually don't look at an alcoholic and
say yeah that's safe that's healthy
that's environmental but when you look
at people that habitually smoke weed
there's this connotation that comes with
it that it's from the earth it's natural
it's for the hippies well take a longer
look into that and I think the studies
are going to reveal that it might not be
so green wholesome and wonderful on down
the road so it's really more the
connotation that goes with it people
have been told it's natural it's healthy
there's nothing wrong with it you can't
OD on it and I think that's a very
dangerous message he's putting out there
especially young people I mean it might
be a dangerous message but it's actually
a fact I believe that no one's ever
medically OD'd on cannabis whereas a lot
of people have OD'd on alcohol alcohol
seems to kill a lot more people than
cannabis does I'm not necessarily
advocating that we Legalize It here I'm
just saying those are two facts which
make it interesting to me that we treat
as a society alcohol in a more liberal
tolerant way than we treat cannabis and
I'm not quite sure why
well I think also you mentioned nobody's
OD well that might be the case but just
because you're not overdosing and dying
doesn't mean that there are not adverse
effects and I think we need to know
those adverse effects for so long you
know the weed lobbying industry has said
oh it's clean it's natural there's no
problem you're not going to OD on it
again a dangerous message let's also
keep in mind that here in the United
States we're having a big problem with
marijuana being laced with fentanyl so
this message that oh it's just weed well
listen you gotta look a little deeper
got to get a little further under the
hood and then we also have to understand
that because we don't have uniform
regulation a lot of this weed that's
being grown the fertilizers being used
are not being regulated the right way so
there are other health side effects that
go along with this Beyond just overdose
that really need to be looked at and
we've got to get under the hood a little
deeper okay but just final point back to
you uh Sean does anything Tommy say
there yeah make you rethink what you're
what you're saying about this well okay
okay so how does turning weed into
account Ice Age rogue solved the problem
you know we've got a South American
country there where the prime minister
or the president has basically told you
know his cops to go out and end people's
lives on the street anyone who's doing
drugs shoots him right kill him and and
that doesn't stop him doing it so how
does turning it giving it a Class A
solve that problem and and and and
really what so we blame him the whole
problem of homelessness and no jobs and
everything else in America on what weed
really
come on
all right let's go to the final word to
You Tommy Lauren come on
growled in a mancunian accent no I'm not
saying our homeless crisis I'm not
saying our homeless crisis can can
entirely be blamed on weed it's mostly
blamed on Democrats and their policies
here in the United States but I'll tell
you this the cities and the states that
have legalized they have seen an influx
of degenerates on their streets that
come there because wheat has been
legalized it doesn't attract the best of
the best go to Denver Colorado go to Los
Angeles go to San Francisco tell me what
you see and I'd also say this about the
whole gateway drug thing not a lot of
individuals start out with a needle in
their arm they start out with something
else so is it a domino effect uh I have
a feeling that there's something to that
you know what it's a fascinating debate
and I can't think of two more unlikely
people to have come together to have it
and yet you both made great points so
that we should we may have to do this
pairing again
um thank you both very much Sean Tommy
really appreciate it thanks peace